greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome at
sea my channel I think I'm slightly out
of focus
I don't know how may also be tilted
slightly but I'm doing my best so today
I'm answering a question that people
keep asking me or rather answering why
I'm not answering the questions people
keep asking me which is where you go
what's your job what are you doing oh my
god
um and I just wanted to be super clear
because there's so much speculation
about this about why I haven't announced
at about when I'm announcing it that
just seems so unnecessary
so first even though I did mention this
in my video I knew people would ask
questions about it so I want to clear it
up
I left i GN it's really weird that I say
that in pastas now I left
ign's is my last day on Friday it's very
weird I left I Jan because I got a job
opportunity that aligns mall with my
ambitions that I see a lot of forward
growth that I see a lot of different
opportunities with that is the reason I
left IGN and not going independent hug
people be like I really hope you didn't
leave Ichan to become a full-time stream
because good luck I'm like again no got
a job in another company that's why this
is happening so the reason that I have
an announcement going and why I don't
know when I can announce where I'm going
is because I'm on a visa in the u.s.
that paperwork is all going through
right now and we're working on that but
I didn't want to announce more I'm going
until I have a start date and the stock
date was supposed to be July 9th
so because we hadn't even submitted the
visa paperwork yet that's like totally
not going to happen so I just don't want
to announce it before I know when I'm
actually going to be working there
because say [ __ ] gets too late even
follow that I have to go to Australia
for a while then I have to come back
here like it would just be weird for me
to say hey I'm going here and then
everyone's gonna be like what what the
[ __ ] are you doing right now
so right now I'm unemployed while I wait
for my visa I just thought it would be
more confusing for me to make that
announcement before everything is done
so as soon as I have the visa is when I
will tell you all where I'm going so to
explain that for anyone who's interested
I'm on an o1 visa which is a visa that
makes me an alien of extraordinary
ability it's the coolest title that I've
been awarded and it is tied to a
specific company meaning that I can live
in the US on the basis that I'm working
for a company even if I wanted to go
full-time youtuber full-time twitch
which for the record I do not totally
don't have those aspirations I love
working as part of it
and walking on like Baker productions
than one person can Paul I legally can't
legally cannot do that I have to be tied
to a company and I couldn't keep my i GN
visa basically the Beasley is
non-transferable so the new company has
to go through all of the paperwork ship
that IGN did for me to get my visa with
them in the first place
[ __ ] my battery's dying and this is like
one of my favorite things that that I
don't really bring up very often but I
doesn't just enjoy thinking about it's
for anyone who's ever like you on the go
job because you're go speaks on camera
no I literally have to prove to the US
government that I'm so qualified for my
job that I wouldn't be stealing it from
another US citizen I have to prove to
the government that I am so qualified
that they consider me extraordinary or
they will not let me have that job like
the stack of paperwork from my visitors
is legitimately not joking about that
big and it's a really complicated system
that um just just takes a while to get
through processing because you have to
gather every document you possibly can
be like here's why
we are employing her he is why she
deserves this job here are all the
skills and all the things that she's
walked on and all the things that she
has done that lead to this job making
sense but because that takes a long time
it just means I don't know when I will
have the visa I would guess in the
middle of July right now I don't know so
I'm just gonna be unemployed for a
couple weeks and I'm very excited about
that but of course I'll let you guys
know as soon as I can I just wanted to
really clear it up because so many
people have these crazy theories for why
I hadn't announced things definitely
plans are in motion it just
my camera battery just died so I thought
that I would just cut here to say
goodbye but I think that's everything
I'll do my ig and exit Q&A in a couple
of weeks I just kind of I don't I want
to be talking about video games again
for a bit rather than just talking about
IGN constantly now that I'm gone so I'll
do that in in a few weeks or so so feel
free to again ask questions in the
comments below if you have any but this
is just an update for you guys really so
I'm Alana and I will see you guys next
time buh-bye